So while looking at the data, we very quickly discovered that the data
showed quite a lot of variance, which was very likely to
impact the accuracy of any regression estimator we might want to build.
To see why this is, consider the opposite end of the spectrum.
The data shows no variance.
In this case, if the values of your features of the same,
the measured response variable, in this case, arrival time is always the same.
That is you have a static functional mapping.
And the learning problem amounts to learning aesthetic functional mapping.
As you introduce variance into this,
it slowly becomes more difficult to predict the response variable as
the introduced variance shows up added to the output of the regression.
To combat this, I considered going the classification route